maybe it's a good time then to segue to
what about us why did you choose this
song to do this morning this is a time
in the world where we need to
be together and stand up for ourselves
and others I always say that I I think
the only way forward is is diversity and
inclusivity and we are a traveling city
of diversity and inclusivity we worship
different gods we love differently we're
different ethnicities we have different
political beliefs we argue we get back
together we we concentrate on what we
have in common instead of what we don't
and we're a traveling City and it works
it's [__] beautiful all right here we
go this is the whole band
oh
[Music]
we
arrive kids pointing up at the stars
foreign
[Music]
disaster
What About Love what about trust What
About Us
we don't want to be solved
we are children
that needs to be loved
we were willing
we came when you called
[Music]
eyes enough is enough
answers
what about us
[Music]
gonna go
yeah yeah
[Music]
addiction Stones they may break these
bones but then I'll be ready are you
ready it's the start of us waking up
come on are you ready
I'll be ready I don't want control I
want to let go
I'll be ready
[Music]
What About Us
what about
what about broken happy ever after
[Music]
wards
What About Us
wow amazing that is some powerful song
there are four women doing your
harmonies with you I'm fascinated by
that these women you hand-picked these
women I like to think they hand-picked
me too
well that's nice we choose each other
every day we choose each other but
you're the boss cool and they're great
and they're just like good people that
are just happen to be insanely talented
and I love harmonies my dad yes so I've
asked other people could you do those
harmonies right now just the you guys
without any music
can I put you on the spot yeah just a
little part of that because it's so nice
what's the key
[Music]
Please
Don't Leave Me
I always say how I don't need you but
it's always gonna come right back to
this
please
don't leave me
come on
foreign